let me start by asking a question just
for the show of hands who has an iPhone
who has an Android phone who has a
blackberry who will admit in public to
having a blackberry and let me guess how
many of you when you arrived here like
me went and bought a pay-as-you-go some
card yeah I bet you didn't even know
you're using African technology
pay-as-you-go was the technology or an
idea pioneered in Africa by a company
called Vodacom a good 15 years ago and
now like franchising pay-as-you-go is
one of the most dominant forces of
economic activity in the world so I'm
going to talk about innovation in Africa
which i think is the purest form
innovation out of necessity but first
I'm gonna ask you some other questions
but you know to put your hands up these
are these are rhetorical why did nikola
tesla have to invent the alternating
current that powers the lights in this
building or the the city that we invited
Henry Ford have to invent the production
line to produce his Ford's that came in
anything as long as they were black and
why did Eric Merrifield have to invent
the dollar's blank stares
that is what $1 looks like and in the
background you can see Robben Island
this is a small dollars and Eric Murray
field is the most famous inventor you've
never heard of in 1963 a storm ripped up
the harbor in a small South African town
called East London and while he was
watching his kids playing with toys made
from oxen bones called dollars's he had
the idea for this it's a bit like a huge
jumping jack and they have used this in
every harbour in the world as a
breakwater the global shipping economy
would not be possible without African
technology like this so whenever you
talk about Africa you have to put up
this picture of the world from space and
people go and look it's the Dark
Continent actually it isn't what it is
is a map of innovation and it's really
easy to see where innovations
going on all the places with lots of
electricity it isn't and the reason it
isn't is because everybody's watching
television or playing Angry Birds so
where it's happening is in Africa now
this is real innovation not the way
people have expropriated the word to
talk about launching new products this
is real innovation and I define it as
problem-solving people are solving real
problems in Africa why because we have
to because we have real problems and
when we solve real problems for people
we solve them for the rest of the world
at the same time so in California
everybody is rarely excited about a
little square of plastic that you plug
into a phone and you can swipe your
credit card and people say we've
liberated the credit card from the
point-of-sale terminal fantastic why do
you even need a credit card in Africa
we've been doing that for years and
we've been doing it on phones like this
this is a picture took at a place called
kitten gala about an hour south of
Nairobi and the thing that's so
remarkable about the payment system
that's been pioneered in Africa called
and pacer is that it works on phones
like this it works on every single phone
possible because it uses SMS you can pay
bills with it you can buy your groceries
you can pay your kids school fees and
I'm told you can even bribe customs
officials something like twenty five
million dollars a day is transacted
through and Pesa 40 percent of Kenya's
GDP moves through in Pesa
using phones like this and you think
this is just a feature phone actually
it's the smart phone of Africa it's also
a radio and it's also a torch and more
than anything else that has really
superb battery life why because that's
what we need we have really severe
energy problems in Africa by the way you
can update facebook and send Gmail from
a phone like this
so we have found a way to use the
available technology to send Manny Vai
and pacer which is a bit like a check
system for the mobile age I come from
Johannesburg which is a mining town it's
built on gold there's a picture I
instagrammed earlier and the difference
today is that the gold of today is
mobile if you think about the the
railroad system in North America and how
that worked first came the
infrastructure
then came the industry around it the
brothels somewhat like the internet
today right and everything else that
that worked with it
bars saloons etc the gold of today is
Mobile in and and mobile is the enable
that makes all of this possible so what
are some of the things that you can do
with it well this is by a guy called
Brad Simon's from Ghana and what you do
is you take medication something that
some people might spend there in time
and salary and you sketch off the code
and you send that to an SMS number and
it tells you if that is legitimate or if
it's expired really simple really
effective really life-saving in Kenya
there's a service called a cow which
just sends you really important
information about how to look after your
dairy a very business in Kenya is a 463
million dollar business and the
difference between a subsistence farmer
and an abundance farmer is only a couple
of litres of milk a day and if you can
do that you can rise out of poverty
really simple using a basic phone if we
don't have electricity no problem we'll
just make it out of old bicycle parts
using a windmill as William come one
murdered there's another great African
that you've heard that's busy disrupting
the the automobile industry in the world
he's also finding a way to reinvent
solar power in the electricity industry
in North America and if he's lucky he'll
get us to Mars hopefully in my lifetime
he comes from Pretoria the capital of
Johannesburg about 50 kilometers from
where I live so back to Joburg which is
sometimes called a gorilla which means
city of gold and not only is mobile the
the gold of today I don't believe that
the gold is under the ground
I believe we
you are the gold like you've heard that
other economist say we are at the point
where China was when its boom years
began and that's where we're going so
you hear you hear the West talk about
innovation at the edge well of course
it's happening at the edge because in
the middle everybody's updating Facebook
or worse still they're trying to
understand Facebook's privacy settings
this is not that catchy catchphrase this
is innovation over the edge so people
like to call Africa a mobile-first
continent but actually that's mobile
only so while everybody else is doing
all of those things we're saving the
world's problems so there's only one
thing left to say
[Applause]